crisis continues to get worse months
after vice president kamala harris's
visit
and the vice president released her root
causes migration strategy today
it focuses on things like economic
inequality
combating corruption and promoting human
rights but critics point out it doesn't
mention securing
the border tucker carlson joins us now
the latest episode of tucker carlson
originals is out today on fox nation
he goes to the epicenter of the border
crisis where americans say they are
forced
to arm themselves watch where's our
federal government nobody's helping us
out
people are afraid in their own homes
right now people are afraid in their own
yards
and i never leave home without a pistol
in my pocket and a dog on my side
not our family feel safe leaving the
house without a gun this is america we
shouldn't have to live in fear in our
own house
it's gonna go to where people are gonna
start freaking dying
and it ain't gonna be us in this town
tucker thanks for joining us today we're
gonna all get a chance to ask you a
little bit of a question
tell me about the overall approach that
you took here to try to bring this story
to everybody that can see it on fox
nation
well i mean the the whole key to
covering the news is to try and think
clearly and just because the other
channels and
and the administration are telling you
that i don't know covid
uh is the biggest story of the moment
doesn't mean that it is and actually
there are a lot of
crises unfolding around the country and
this is the greatest of all our southern
border is open
we're going to get literally millions of
foreign nationals into our country
illegally
this year and the overwhelming majority
will stay and the new york times today
announced that they should all be
allowed to vote and choose our next
government et cetera so this is a
there's a massive transformation you can
be for it i mean some people are for it
of course that's why it's happening so
people
can be against it but you should know
what's happening and the people who live
you know within 50 miles of the border
have had their lives completely
transformed and destroyed in a lot of
cases because of it there are victims of
this it's not a victimless crime
at all and we felt duty bound
to show what it looks like and you know
what do they think of it like let's say
you live in uvalde texas what is
you know what is your life like can your
kids go to school answered no
because the border is open and for some
reason no one is telling the story i
must have seen
15 stories about people who didn't get
the vaccine and they're sick and they
deserve it i mean that's like the lead
of every
every website in the world right now
okay
but you know maybe there are other
people suffering and maybe we should
tell their story so we did
and that's what this is about katie
we'll take it around the table here hey
tucker uh congrats on this new special i
think it's a really important topic
um you know from the the other part of
this is the vice president who
has been tasked and put out these
talking points which we've been seeing
for 30 years on this issue and yesterday
the state department announced that
they're actually cutting off ties to
the attorney general's office in
guatemala because of a lack of
cooperation on corruption issues
so how do people fee there feel about
the way that washington is
ignoring this issue and just putting out
talking points
i'm sorry i mean i'm a patron i'm as
patriotic i think as anybody it's but
it's not guatemala's fault it's not el
salvador's fault it's not
right it's not honduras fault and it's
not even mexico's fault it's our fault
we do two things one we provide a
massive incentive
to people for people to come here by
providing the most generous welfare
benefits
in the world to the people who come
illegally and two by opening the borders
and summoning them
so to whip around and blame climate
change or the government of honduras or
corruption as if we can
as if we can fix that i mean imagine the
hubris required to say okay
all we need to do is change 300
years of custom in a country whose
language we don't speak
and we'll have it fixed i mean like you
truly are a [ __ ]
if you say something like that i mean
honestly no it's our fault
it's our welfare benefits and our open
border it's that simple geraldo
hey tuck uh you know it's a stop uh
subject near and dear to my heart
yeah i am glad that you didn't lead with
the migrants bringing
kovid in as uh as too many reports that
i've seen
in recent days do because those
overblown health
fears are the uh the xenophobic reaction
to immigrants since the irish
in the 19th century in the 19th century
the chinese in the 1880s the italians
right
we live in a country where we are being
forced to take a vaccine that some
people
news flash don't want to take that
americans can be arrested for not
wearing a mask because covet is so
serious but foreign nationals break our
laws carrying covet and somehow they're
exempt from the requirements that we
live under
that's not xenophobia that's equal
application of the law and it's not
happening now and it's an appalling
double standard that every american
including you should be mad about
well i'm mad about exaggeration and hype
if what it's a policy they are not
forcing
look if you work in the federal
government you have to get the vaccine
but if you break our laws as an illegal
alien you don't
why don't you explain why that's a good
idea to me well i i don't think the
segment's about me i would be glad to
but i think i would rather refer to uh
let jessie be the subject okay and and
greg's going to ask you about fishing
tucker this is what we've been dealing
with all week with geraldo
so i'm just my apologies on on the show
we love him too but um sometimes he
needs a little tough love
uh i caught last night some of the clip
that you promoted and
one of these homeowners female was
packing heat
and she never did that before it was the
first time she had to do this because
she said cartels
were operating on our side of the border
and tell me what you thought about that
comment
mexico is one of the most dangerous
countries in the world you know i i grew
up right near mexico i really like
mexico
and i like people who live in mexico um
but there's a war going on in mexico
which we never
even acknowledge people who live near it
are very aware of it but there's
literally a war i mean not long ago
the mexican military backed down in the
face
of the cartels because the cartels were
better armed so that's the context here
and we ignore that it's not just you
know these are not people just searching
for a better life these are refugees
from a war zone and that has massive
implications for us
as to the fact people down there are
armed yeah and it really should make all
of us wonder why would the federal
government try to be disarming
us which they are trying to do at
exactly the moment when they're
increasing
the threat to us as they are also doing
like what is that i'd love to know
what that's about last question from
greg
tucker good to see you on the five even
though you said you couldn't do my show
but that's okay
because i was doing this show man that's
that's not enough
i thought we were friends all right so i
want to talk about some
some guy got in your face at some
fishing store in montana fishing store
is that what you call it yeah i call it
a fly shop what's up thank you
so so i'm mean i was like i find it very
frustrating that adult men are now
becoming like mean girls like
he could have come up to you and
actually expressed himself
and been and you could have had a
conversation but he couldn't do that
without somebody
filming it because he knew that if he
had that little
someone to film it that would impact
your response
which as a wise person in the media you
know that now you just look and you just
go okay see you later
i'm wondering what you would have done
if the person wasn't filming it because
you might had a conversation
hassling me in front of one of my kids i
mean i had some you know i had some dark
thoughts which i'm not going to
articulate here
i will say that the bigger i mean
leaving me totally out of it
the bigger problem is that the mountain
states have been completely invaded by
the people who destroyed california and
what's so interesting
is they're the exact same people who
lecture you day night about diversity
and it's so important and you're a
racist etc etc
and then they run to montana with the
same
at it they literally run from the hills
away from
diversity and the hills greatly suffer
when they do that
i'll leave it there why don't you whack
him
tucker style all right tucker crosston
thanks congrats on the special we'll
definitely take a look at it we
appreciate it
thanks so much for having me good to see
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else